okay let's continue with even more good
stuff metropolis light transport
straight from 97 the key idea is to seek
the light this is the thing that I
always hear from the artists who use the
algorithm what we are trying to do is
sampling brighter light paths more often
than darker light paths that's it that's
the basic principle that's what we're
trying to do and educated people would
immediately say that hey but isn't this
what we have been talking about at
important sampling isn't this
conflicting with important sampling what
is important sampling well it means that
if I have for instance a glossy
reflection applause EB RDF which has a
really high probability of sending Rays
out in the perfect reflection direction
so almost like a mirror with a higher
probability it would behave like a
mirror then I would like to have a high
probability of actually sampling that
light path proportional to the shape of
the B earlier and this we can do through
important sampling okay but imagine a
case where you would have a glossy
reflection covered from almost every
direction by black bodies so it doesn't
matter if I important sample the brdf
correctly because after I important
sample the brdf and the light is coming
to the next bounce it is always gonna
hit a black body and it's gonna be
absorbed
I'm never gonna continue my last light
path afterwards so even though I would
important sample these like this one
bounce I am NOT important sampling along
the whole path because I have important
sampled this one bounced correctly but I
didn't know that globally I'm just
heading to a region that's really dark
and what metropolis light transport
gives you is something that is not
really referred to but I like to call it
multi bounce important sampling so it
may take suboptimal decisions and it may
send out Ray's in other
action that is not so likely for your
brdf if it knows that it's going to end
up being a bright light path so for
instance if you have a glassy inter
reflection that would be mostly sending
rays out in this direction but there is
complete darkness in there then it would
it would what it would do is it would
actually send more rays towards the
light source which looks like a
suboptimal decision in there in that
brdf but over the whole light path that
is actually going to be something bright
so this is the key idea behind
metropolis light transport and I'd like
to give you an intuitive example of that
so imagine that you have the camera in
this room in the scene and you have a
light source only in the only in the
adjacent room in the next room and this
next room is separated by a wall and the
door that is slightly ajar so it is just
opened just a bit and all the light that
you see is coming through that door and
if you imagine for now naive path
tracing what am i doing I am sending a
ray through the first pixel and I'm
going to bounce it around the scene and
it is very likely that I will never find
a light source and I cannot even connect
to the light source it's in the other
room I'm going to hit the wall or the
door and imagine that I'm computing
thousands and thousands of samples and I
finally get to hit the light path that
is actually connectable to a light
source if we are doing Park tracing you
can imagine that I'm starting from here
if you take a look at the arrow in there
it gives you the intuition that maybe we
are doing light tracing we are shooting
light rays of light from the light
source and we finally get into this
and heat the camera ders finally a good
connection after thousands and thousands
of samples I finally have one
contribution before that zero zero zero
zero zero and my CPU is basically dying
on 100 percent load nothing gets out
there now imagine that I finally found a
light path that makes sense that has a
contribution and then I would suddenly
forget about the whole thing and I would
again start sampling completely random
light paths and get to zero zero zero
again now it would be a crime to do that
wouldn't it
what metropolis is doing is essentially
trying to remember which are the paths
that make sense and if they find
something like that they are going to
explore nearby so they are not going to
shoot out a completely random sample for
the next sample it's going to take this
one sample that made sense finally a
connection and then it's going to add
very small perturbations to this light
path what if I shoot this in an angle
it's just a bit changed and what you can
expect is that most of the time it will
give you again some amount of
contribution and you don't have to start
from scratch so basically you can use
all of these knowledge in to your
advantage
how does the difference look like well
this is the scene with bidirectional
part racing after 40 samples per pixel
and now if you look closely you will see
metropolis after the very same number of
samples per pixel so this is
bidirectional part racing and now
metropolis with the same number of
samples so if you take this knowledge
into account most of your samples are
going to be useful just another look
rather actually part racing metropolis
and bidirectional was already a good
algorithm it's not a nice path tracer
it's it's a good algorithm a naive path
tracing will be even worse another
example some nice volumetric caustics
with naive part racing
and an equal time comparison with
metropolis light transport how does it
work exactly mathematical details but
just enough just enough to understand
the intuition what we're trying to do is
important sampling what does it mean it
means that I am computing discrete
samples of F over P F is the function
that I would like to integrate P is a
sampling distribution what I'm looking
for is to match the blue lines with the
green bars if you remember so it means
that if the function is large summer it
means that the image is bright somewhere
or the path space is bright somewhere
then I would like to put more samples in
there so if F is large then P should
also be large this is what I'm trying to
achieve now how do I actually do this I
have some high dimensional function or
if I'm doing locally important something
then I have a brdf function how do I
important sample this the trivial
solution is called rejection sampling
basically what it means is that I would
like to compute samples from a sampling
distribution so here you see something
that is like almost a Gaussian but
imagine that I cannot generate samples
out of this function because what do I
have in my C++ code well I can generate
uniform random numbers but this function
is not uniform random numbers so what I
can do is I can sample an arbitrary
distribution function if I enclose it in
a box and I throw completely uniform
random samples on this box so it is
almost like drawing your function on a
sheet of paper and throwing random
samples at it now I cannot generate
random samples out of this function but
I can generate random uniformly
distributed samples
and the scheme is very simple if it is
under the function I'm going to take
this sample and pretend that I've
generated that sample in the first place
and if it's out there I'm just going to
kick it out so if I do this I would have
samples according to this almost
Gaussian this works well but this is not
what we're doing in practice this is
very inefficient and hopefully you can
see from the image why this is an
inefficient technique to do so
someone please raise your hand and help
me out why this is not efficient okay
that's true Thanks
so there's tons of rejected samples most
of my uniformly generated random numbers
are completely wasted again so there
must be some technique that's better
than this well there is but I guarantee
that it's not going to make you any
happier when you see how it is done so
there's lots of rejection there's lots
of rejections and this can be
analytically this problem can almost
always be analytically solved by a
technique called the inverse transform
sampling or the Smirnoff transform and
this takes a bit of work but I'll just
briefly show you how it works and if you
are really interested in the details
then please take a look at this document
so I show you what you have to do you
have to do all of these calculations and
then you will have your sampling
distribution okay what do we have at the
end let's start with the intuition we
have uniformly generated random numbers
this is the c1 and c2 at the end and I
want to do some transform to these
numbers in order to get an arbitrary
sampling distribution and what they are
essentially doing is you have a
probability distribution function you
want to sample from that it can be like
a Poisson distribution an exponential
distribution or some custom brdf and if
you integrate the
da-fu are going to have a cdf so you
integrate the probability distribution
function you will get a cumulative
distribution function and this can help
you in this transformation from
uniformly generated random numbers to
the actual function now this is very
intimidating isn't it
imagine that whenever you come up with a
new brdf for any kind of function that
you would like to sample you would have
to compute all this and not only that we
were doing this for brdf so I can
important sample one bounce again I
emphasize that it means that if I hit a
hit the table I locally know what are
the good outgoing directions because of
the material model but it doesn't mean
that it's globally a good idea because
there may be this completely black
curtain next to it which I'm going to
get and all of the energy is going to be
absorbed
what does metropolis give us a solution
to this so it's it's important sampling
not only for one we RDF not only for all
possible brdf but an optimal important
sampling along the whole path so this
means that it will know that if there is
a path that is 15 bounds long but it
hits something that is really bright and
it transfers a lot of energy it will
know that I will need to sample this
light path and nearby and it is not
going to trace many rays towards the
shadowed regions
how does it work again intuitively it
wants a Markov chain process and there
is for Markov chains there is a steady
state distribution this means that we
have been running the Markov chain for a
while and if you do that then it
promises you optimal important sampling
for any kind of function without doing
anything and I hope that it is
understandable how really amazing this
is because it is actually a simple
sampling scheme that you can write down
the pseudocode
in five or six lines and it gives you
optimally important something so this is
really amazing and I emphasize again
that this is over multiple bounds is not
important something one brdf but over
whole light paths there are different
different variants of metropolis light
transport the original is the beach type
metropolis this is the one that was
published in 97 it is a great algorithm
it has different mutational strategies
it means that it has different
strategies of changing the current light
path into a new one in a smart way and
not randomly the problem is that almost
no one in the world can implement it
correctly so it was published in 97 and
the first viable implementation that
came out was in the Mitsuba render
implemented by dancer Jakob and it was
around I think 2010 so just a few years
ago Metro put the original metropolis
light transport also attributed to Eric
reach no one in the world could
implement it I honestly don't know what
was going on because he published it in
97 and it took the very least 13 years
for the first super smart guy to
implement correctly I don't know what he
was doing in the meantime maybe he was
laughing on humanity that no one is
smart enough to to deal with this and
maybe we don't deserve this algorithm I
don't know it's it's not for the faint
of the heart it's a really difficult
algorithm yes
he's working for Google that's true
after after the PhD he did he go
immediately to Google so he's basically
working on Adwords how to get more money
out of advertisements it definitely pays
well and who knows I mean that if Eric
which is working on it that there's
there's gonna be some good stuff in
there I guarantee you
but I have to say that that his face
looked actually quite delighted when he
got the academy award just recently for
his work that was the very least 15
years ago it's it's still used all over
the industry multiple important sampling
bidirectional are facing metropolis it's
all over the industry now the rich style
metropolis is really difficult
fortunately there are also smart people
at my former university namely Chapo
Kellerman and last lost Illinois College
they came up with a simplified version
of the algorithm which is almost as
robust but is actually quite revealed to
implement it has also implemented in
small paint it is called the primary
sample space metropolis it is now
implemented by one of my students from a
previous year rendering course and it is
in small pen so you can give it a try
basically it does complicated sounding
but otherwise simple mapping from an
infinite dimensional cube where I can
generate infinite dimensional cube means
arbitrarily long vectors of independent
randomly uniform random generated
numbers and these random numbers are
somehow transformed into light paths so
what the algorithm does is there's a
probability that I am computing a
completely new light path and if I don't
have this probability it and I'm going
to stay around this light path and
explore nearby what does it mean
practically if I find this super
difficult light path from the other room
to here then I find a really bright
light path the algorithm will know that
okay I'm just going to add slight
perturbations to this light path I'm
going to stay around here and sometimes
it will start to look around for random
samples there's also a visualization
video on YouTube if you take a look you
will immediately understand what is
going on and some literature about these
algorithms now it is also
a sampling scheme so metropolis you can
implement together with path tracing or
bi-directional path tracing and
therefore this is also an unbiased and
consistent algorithm and it is very
robust it is tailored for really
difficult scenes so if you have a scene
with a lot of occlusions difficult to
sample light source is difficult to
reach light sources use the metropolis
but if you have an easy scene this is
not going to give you much because the
metropolis is a smart algorithm it takes
longer to compute one sample than a path
tracer and if the smart behavior of the
algorithm it does not pay off then there
may be scenes where the metropolis is
actually worse than a graph tracer so if
you have an outdoor scene with large
light sources and the environment match
that you hit all the time don't use
metropolis it doesn't give you anything
path tracing would give you better
results because it can dish out more
samples per pixel because it's dumped
and it paralyzes even better and only
the number of samples matter in this
case and there may be algorithms that
take this into consideration so what if
we have an algorithm that could
determine if we have an easy scene or a
difficult scene and it could use for
easy scenes easy naive path tracing
bi-directional processing or if there is
a difficult scene then it would use
metropolis light transport now this
would need an algorithm that can somehow
determine whether the scene is easy or
hard and that's that's not trivial at
all to do but behind this link there is
a work that deals with it and I would
also like to note that metropolis light
transport is unbiased but it starts out
biased so what it means is that I'm
running a Markov chain that will give me
optimal important sampling but if this
Markov chain also evolves in time so I
have to wait and wait and wait and it
will get better and better as
nations on the where the bright paths
are and where the dark paths are and
this takes time
this effect is what we call startup
virus now what do we get for it we'll
see plenty of examples so for instance
on caustics it's even better than
bidirectional path tracing for caustics
you will get almost immediate
convergence now what about this scene
this scene was rendered with Lux render
here you have not glass spheres but some
kind of Prizm material spheres because
you can see a pronounced effect of
dispersion and you can see volumetric
caustics so there is a participating
media that we are in and these caustics
are going to be reflected multiple times
and refracted multiple times let's say
that this is a disgustingly difficult
scene the only light source there is is
actually this laser that comes in from
the upper left let's try to render such
a scene with the different algorithms
that we have learned about now if I
start a podracer this is what I will get
after 10 minutes so the high-scoring
light paths the bright light paths are
not the greatest probability light paths
and therefore most of the connections
will be also obstructed towards the
light source so it is very difficult to
sample with path tracing bi-directional
path tracing it's better but I mean if I
get this after 10 minutes I don't know
how long it would take to render the
actual scene and if you are on
metropolis it will find the light paths
that matter and find the ones that are
actually needed to be sampled and this
this is the sim already the simplified
version PS SL T and the number next to
it is just a ratio of these small
perturbations to large perturbations
sorry the opposite so a large number
means that most of my light paths are
going to be random so most of with a 75%
problem
I'm going to do by direction of our
facing 25 percent metropolis and if I
pull down this probability or point 25
then most of the time I'm going to do
metropolis sampling I'm going to explore
nearby and you can see that this renders
the scene much much faster so this is
definitely a very useful technique to
have now I've done this animation just
for fun this is a primary sample space
metropolis light transport algorithm
only with small mutations so just very
small adjustments to the light paths and
this is how an image would converge with
these small steps and you can see that
the caustics converge ridiculously
quickly now let's take a look at one
more example
take a look at this most of the scene is
still noisy but the caustics are
completely converged as we start out why
because it is really bright and this is
exactly what the metropolis is going to
focus on so it is even better round
caustics something that takes a brutal
amount of samples with a normal part
tracer is going to be immediately
converged with the metropolis so this is
the first I think ten perhaps ten
minutes of rendering with the metropolis
on a not so powerful machine so it seems
that we have solved everything we're
looking good we got this but I will show
you a failure case that we actually
still have problems that we couldn't
solve this is a sophisticated scene that
is for it for some reason even harder in
some sense than the previous scenes and
it just doesn't want to converge with
the primary sample space metropolis a
I'm just rendering and running and still
fireflies if I have really large really
bright noisy spots then this means that
I have light paths that are that have a
ridiculously low probability to be
visited and that means that my sampling
strategies are not smart enough and this
is a classical long-standing problem in
global illumination metropolis is not a
solution for this it is still not good
enough but there are techniques that can
give you a really smooth results on
ridiculously difficult scenes like this
and I will also explain you during the
next lecture why is this essentially
difficult because doesn't seem to
intuitive does it but I will explain to
you during the next lecture thank you
very much